[Music]
so today's the gold rush this has been a
city of free thinkers and I don't have
to remind you about the Summer of Love
right across the bay in San Francisco
I would got to Oakland I'm not quite so
sure but that's the question
[Music]
hi my name is Sawa Abraham and welcome
to Oaksterdam Oaksterdam does come from
combining Oakland and Amsterdam
obviously and that is our working model
you know that's the you know a lot of
activists and the 90s went to Amsterdam
and you know look at that and said hey
we can do this here you know it shows it
can work current Oaksterdam is fans from
19th Street to Broadway to sick 15th
Street down to Webster and that's kind
of the pot friendly district moving
along now we're at the campaign
headquarters this is actually the second
home of Oaksterdam right now we are
running the tax and regulate cannabis
campaign out of this office and after
the campaign is over and we win in on
November 2nd it will be converted into a
visitor center in Museum Manik
Oaksterdam University is the major
sponsor for tax cannabis 2010 the
started last March when we did a poll
that showed for the first time a
majority of California voters in favor
of legalization tax and regulate
cannabis is in this statewide initiative
that would allow for adults 21 years of
age and older to possess up to an ounce
and cultivate 25 square feet it'll also
allow for cities and counties to decide
how an if they would like to tax the
commercial sales and commercial
cultivation
new Oaksterdam University
our sim university started after I went
to Amsterdam in 2006 and I saw the
cannabis college there which is like a
little information center but then in
2007 I was thinking about new projects
to do and canvas College thought it'd be
a good idea to take it to the next level
actually having classes we've ran an ad
in the East Bay express the local
alternative weekly here and within
minutes of it hitting the newsstands the
phones are ringing off the hook and so
we realized we had to do it then because
the demand was so great semester
students on their first day plant a seed
and they go through the whole process of
the plant all the way up to harvest and
at the end we get donate the medicine to
a patient who can't grow for herself
we're currently growing for a patient
named Yvonne white she's confined to a
wheelchair she's an MS patient very soon
we'll we will have graduated 10,000
students classes that we try to
emphasize the most or like legal issues
knowing your rights you know politics
and history and advocacy knowing that I
have the opportunity to reach out and
speak to these students is just
wonderful for me I love the idea of
being able to hopefully activate them
get them out there organizing and
helping us to finally legalize cannabis
once and for all and it's just really
important that people know kind of where
this whole movement came from and where
we're going and really trying to get
people involved because that's the only
way we're gonna be able to accomplish
anything well I am a nurse I'm a
registered nurse with a bachelor's
degree who has run hospice home health
and adult day health care in my County
I'm here because I believe in the
medicine itself that it does work and it
does take care of a lot of ailments and
I believe that our can at our country is
in a prescription drug crisis and I
think that we need to be looking at
alternative medicines for pain and
symptom management it's really
interesting how this whole industry is
shaping up and Oaksterdam University is
really instrumental in providing and
sort of an accreditation
to this we'd love it if your viewers
came on down and signed up for classes
we got lots of spots available coming up
for this summer and fall across the
street is the Bulldog coffee shop it's
the second cannabis outlet in Oaksterdam
one of the reasons we named ourselves
the Bulldog coffee shop our first
college coffee shop named it after the
Bulldog and Amsterdam because they were
so tenacious you know that they were
getting bested sometimes more than once
a week but they just kept reopening and
now the Bulldog has like seven locations
a couple hotels and restaurants they pay
millions of dollars in taxes so this is
coffee shop blue sky coffee shop blue
sky is one of the permanent dispensaries
here in Oakland the front acts as a
regular coffee shop it's open to the
public and the back is where you would
get your medicine from we really have
tried hard to sweep the sidewalks and be
good neighbors and help improve the area
and so the neighborhood the neighbors
know that it's not a secret it's okay we
are actually helping revitalize this
community put energy and be about
improving your community improving the
neighborhood and so we're offering like
a safe environment for our patients and
for our neighbors coffee shop blue sky I
think that's aphrodite and she's holding
a joint
I mean she's really as holding a joint
like I don't know what else about could
be and so this is the extra name gift
shop here welcome to come in and this is
a sweatshirt from the San Francisco
cannabis buyers club it's the first ever
dispensary in San Francisco and then
there's a petition for the prop 215 and
we've just been collecting little
artifacts here and there ultimately when
we're done fighting the drug war we're
gonna need to have like some sort of
chronicle of our adventure and so it
would be really nice to you know have a
museum here in Oaksterdam the reason
Oaksterdam is the way it is now is
because of a lot of hard work and
courage a lot of people over the years
jeff jones and jim McClellan and there's
just no known a lot of names a lot of
them not no longer with us AIDS patients
from back then who stood up and said you
know take me first you know we're gonna
open up these Medical dispensaries and
you want to stop us you're gonna have to
come arrest this the forces of
opposition Oakland so this is just a
wonderful place to be getting involved
it's kind of the epicenter of the
movement I'd almost say I think
everybody kind of understands that our
current drug policy has failed and by
route taxing and regulating cannabis
will make for safer communities and
allow for the state to have a chance to
get out of its budget deficit California
is a decriminalized state and it's
medical marijuana state and we're still
arresting you know 75,000 people a year
that's outrageous it's a waste of
resources people are really asking
questions about why are we wasting
taxpayers money trying to arrest
prosecute and imprison marijuana
offenders when we could be repeating tax
benefits from a legally regulated market
right now this drug violence going on
down in Mexico it's awful and I can tell
you one thing for certain the drug
cartels do not want you to vote YES on
the tax cannabis and
Americans have a right to drink alcohol
but smoke cigarettes and have guns then
they have a right to smoke a joint it's
as simple as that
[Music]
[Music]